i realized that you know as the director
it's your job to
it's not your job to tell everyone what
to do all the time it's your job to get
the most out of the people that you're
working with
hey
you're one of their refugees
but he's not from around here
if you're not going about an asylum
plane
please hang up
[Music]
you ever think about
who you were
[Music]
our session today looks at the film
limbo
set and shot in scotland um it's an
award-winning film which includes wins
at the back to scotland awards and the
beefas it's globally critically
acclaimed and has been a fast audience
favorite now we are so excited to be
joined today by writer director ben
sharrick as we dig into the process of
making and sharing limbo with the world
um i will say we were due to have
producer irony gertabai with us as well
but she's been unable to join us as um
she's got a four month old who is a
little bit under the weather today but
um ben will have lots of insight for us
so i'm sure i'm sure we'll dig into all
everything with him some of the people
watching may not know um about your
journey as a filmmaker so i think it'd
be quite good to get some sort of
insight into how did you come to making
film and how is it that you and irony
started working together because most of
your projects possibly all your projects
you've made together could you give us a
bit of insight into that
yeah i mean just to say as well from my
side it's a real shame that irina can't
join us
we're a filmmaking partnership we're
also married to it's also my baby that's
not well he's he's doing a lot better
he's okay uh
but um
but yeah so our our kind of stories and
our journey
our journeys you know towards
being filmmakers is very sort of
interconnected so my undergraduate
degree was was in arabic and politics
and
and
then
i spent my third year in syria and it
was actually during my time there that i
started thinking about
film and started kind of imagining
um
short stories in my mind and kind of
then thinking oh maybe i need to write
these down and i i
came back from my final year of
university and
and there was a module available on
middle eastern cinema and
and so then basically i ended up
specializing in middle eastern cinema
in my final year and writing my
dissertation around that subject and
hosting middle eastern film nights at
the university and
i was really inspired by the films i was
seeing from um
throughout the middle east arabic films
and from iran as well
and it was after seeing
elias suleiman's film the time that
remains and then in quite quick
succession um the film called the band's
visit by aaron colleran that i decided i
wanted to be a film director and my next
move
you know at that point like looking at
kind of
graduate schemes in aldi and things like
that that my next move would be to to go
to film school so i finished the exams
on friday shot my first one on the
sunday which i needed to get into film
school and i borrowed some friend from
some equipment from a family friend and
shocked it with my mom and dad in the
house and all of that and then sent it
off and then
had my interview and then ended up going
to um screen academy scotland and
edinburgh for the master's program and
that's where i met the rooney
and
we
started to work together
initially actually rooney was studying
cinematography
and we started to work together as a
cinematographer director and then
she done a lot of producing in her
undergraduate degree and then she ended
up kind of producing
my graduate film
and and we also became a couple
and and then we ended up going to
dubai
straight after the masters and and we
were both working there in advertising
she was working
in production with a production company
i was working
as a creative in an agency
and then we realized that
um we both wanted to make films we both
wanted to make feature films and not
commercials um
so we were kind of trying to find a way
out in a way to do that and then we
ended up getting scholarships to come
back
to screen academy scotland and to do
their mfa program we joined the program
as a partnership as a producer director
uh relationship and
we worked towards our final film and
that it was kind of was quite self-led
and you work towards a film at the end
of it sort of a year and a half long
the film that we had was actually a
short film and that was set in the
safari refugee camps in southern algeria
and we ended up going out there working
with an ngo
and also kind of developing the short
story uh the short film
and then
we weren't able to make that film
because we couldn't get the insurance to
go back out because al qaeda started
operating in the area so it's too
dangerous and then that's how picadero
came about which was my first feature
film and rooney's as well which was
self-funded a self-funded low-budget
film um
which we made a short version of for the
mfa and then and then shortly after we
made the feature film version and then
that premiered in san sebastian film
festival since then we've just been
making films really and that we've been
quite lucky because
we sort of immediately came out of film
school and
made picadero
and then we were sort of then we kind of
we made it outside of the industry and
with very little money
um but we kind of attracted the
attention of of the industry and off the
back of that
i got an agent and all that kind of
thing so then
then following that it was you know it
was everything was sort of focused on on
limbo but that was a very
long process and so limbo does that have
then roots in that short film that you
never got to make like what what brought
you to limbo did you did you find the
film quite quickly or was it a subject
matter that you knew you wanted to
explore but it took a bit of a while to
figure out how you were going to explore
it
yeah exactly
so following picadero it was kind of
i'd already sort of
started to
not establish started to establish maybe
my kind of process or think about my
process and how i kind of formulate
ideas conceptualize things and with
picadero
what it started with was a subject
matter which was the economic crisis and
how that affects young
how that was affecting young people in
in spain and particularly in the in the
basque
region
in the context of piccadero
and
and then finding a way to talk about
that subject matter as a backdrop
um
and putting a sort of very human story
in the foreground
so
um
after kind of taking the journey the
film festival journey all of that kind
of thing with piccadilly and it was time
to kind of you know what's the next
project
i was still very interested in
um
in the refugee subject matter and i felt
like it was you know something that was
i was very passionate about and it felt
like there was unfinished business there
and it started there it started with the
subject matter but then it was a long
process of figuring out
how to
approach that subject matter how to tell
a story
with that subject matter but also
with my sensibility as a filmmaker and
my voice and and doing things that that
i wanted to to achieve creatively how
did you decide to take it from that sort
of refugee camp setting and bring it to
scotland what made you kind of go
this is the story needs to be told here
what was it was there something that
kind of sparked that or was it just um
you were determined to make a film in
scotland what was it that made you do
that
i think it was a combination of things
because i think it started with
you know like a huge amount of research
and and
all you know a lot of different kinds of
research as well um you know watching
other films watching documentaries
reading books newspaper articles
academic essays speaking to people that
have been through the asylum system
speaking to organizations that work with
with asylum seekers and i think that
what came up which what kept coming up
was this this space
kind of in between before getting leaf
remain that space of being in being in
limbo and how damaging um that can be
and also
um
the other
key part of it was identity and and that
was what we were actually working on in
the refugee camps in
in southern algeria the project was
about
identity and about
how
um the label of being a refugee affects
identity so that was really kind of at
the core of it i knew that it was so
what i wanted to write about was that
that period of time being in limbo and
about being identity and about um
the character kind of coming to
terms with his identity
as a refugee and
but you know it was it took a a long
time and there were a few different
iterations and a few different ideas and
you know originally the project was
going to be set set in the arctic and it
was to do with
the polar crossing um
through through um russia in into
finland
um
and
we
actually ended up location sort of
location scouting within the development
process in iceland and we were invited
to reykjavik film festival and then we
managed to get a little bit of funding
to extend our trip
and
travel around the northwest fjords um
and it was there that
that i realized that this film can be in
scotland so you know
you know we were in these tiny fishing
villages in in the middle of nowhere
there's so vastness of the landscape and
i think that creatively those things
were in my mind quite early on is using
the landscape and kind of how that how
the land escape in the environment can
be alienating and creating this feeling
of isolation in the character um
and how that kind of corresponds with
with what he's going through in terms of
his identity and then also obviously
it being the arctic kind of environment
and
iceland that also
stayed with me as well and wanting to
use that kind of
um you know wintry environment and you
know the northern lights that we were
chasing
the entire time that we were in iceland
when we were there for prime northern
light season and we'd never saw them
uh so then we thought i would just
create them in the film instead
and so that development process i mean
it sounds like you were working on this
for quite a while before you found the
story you wanted to tell
a couple of questions about that one
would be around
you know how you and i really work
together in those sort of early
development process is it is it
something that you're constantly um in
conversation about or do you go away and
try and figure out something by yourself
and and how long did that process
go on until you you went to um your
funders and said we've got a film for
you
give us money to develop it like what
how how long was that process
yeah so
i mean so to answer your first question
that we were is interesting because we
were just talking about this a little
bit because we've just had a baby and
i'm realizing kind of how
now how integral rooney is to my writing
process because
before i would be able to just you know
walk into the kitchen at any point not
that she's always in the kitchen or
whatever room she was in uh and
and start talking about the film and
start talking about what's in my head
and and kind of bouncing ideas off her
and you know or if i was kind of
wrestling with a problem to just kind of
go to her and try and talk things out
and
so i was really lucky to have that and
now you know with a baby you just can't
do that anymore so
it sort of goes in stages because she's
quite a big part of that
because you go through so so many
different ideas and tried to like talk
things out and think what's gonna work
so that'll be quite sort of constant
conversation
um
and then i think i kind of go into my
head for quite a long time and just try
and get to that next point where i'm
sort of ready to talk about it um
but having that person who you kind of
absolutely trust and you also know
um
can sort of see in
to your head and
you know know see your vision as well
and understands your vision and
understands what what you want to
achieve creatively to have that is so
important so how long was it just the
two of you and at what point did you
then start to have other people come in
and and you know were you going out and
did you know who you wanted to pitch to
um did you pitch to a number of
different people like what what was that
process like so after piccadero
at that time
um there was the
um
scottish film talent network
um and they had a first feature fund and
we were sort of in a bit of a loophole
because
we had made a feature film and that
feature film had
been around the world and
been to a-list festivals and had also
been released in cinemas in different
countries in europe but it hadn't been
released in the uk
and theatrically and it wasn't funded by
the industry so basically they let us
have that first feature access to that
first feature fund
um
but the way that they did it was also
really useful because they were very
hands-off and they were like okay we
want to support you
um but you've already kind of made a
feature film you've already proven
yourself so we're just going to let you
get on with it
and
having that space and time to explore
the idea and what was next um
and different iterations of the idea
without having that kind of like
pressure or
or a kind of thunder sort of hanging
over you
was
just so
useful sfdn funded the first two drafts
of of the screenplay
um
and then
um
we
sent it to
[Music]
film four and we sent it to bbc films
and on a second draft i mean like you
know an external second draft and it
internal sort of like hundreds
yeah
we were very lucky to get offers from
both um
and
we were very adamant that we wanted to
shoot the film in
november 2018 because of
the kind of creative elements in in the
film um
and basically we film four kind of
backed us at that point for production
and they were like okay we'll shoot it
in this year in october november we're
going to back up production
we went with them
and they kept their promise and and we
were
shooting that november so
amazing that's
it's a bit of a dream process isn't it
when it everything falls into place that
quickly and and so then was that the
point at which angus lamont came on as a
producer as well and and how did that
change the dynamic because obviously you
and irony are the solid team that have
always been working together and now you
have another producer come in
that and also this is your first film
where you've got funding and it's not
it's not just everything is is on the
two of you
um what was what was that process like
yeah that was it was i mean it was
amazing with angus he was brilliant by
the time angus came on we already had
that commitment
to we had we already had the funding in
place
um
and
the financiers were also really good
about it because
rooney wanted to have another producer
and a more experienced producer to work
with
um
and we were talking about a few
different ways to do that whether to
have like an executive producer that
sort of oversees things or to have an
actual
like
you know another producer to
to work with um
and
um
she decided that she would prefer to
have another producer rather than just
having a kind of exec that you can call
up and just sort of oversees things and
that maybe is not as committed we
started sending
the script out and we spoke to a few
different
producers and to come on board and and
you know
that was also
so that person understood
what
my process was and also what the working
relationship was between me and rooney
and what we made very clear from the
beginning was that really
the sort of creative side of it is with
me and aruna so we weren't looking for a
producer to come in
and in a creative context what we were
looking for was a producer to help
rooney navigate
the producing side of of
um
the film in
this the context of having a fully
financed film with a much bigger budget
than
than she'd ever dealt with i think as
soon as we met angus we kind of knew
that he was
the one and that we wanted to work with
and and
he
and he was just brilliant all the way
through he was such a kind of
he was very respectful of
um nina rooney's relationship of kind of
my process and how he sort of fits into
that and and he just kind of did it
perfectly um
and uh yeah and so you know like he's he
i mean he's still kind of quite a
big part of our lives because we still
speak to him all the time uh
and yeah yeah when when you find those
people that you can work with really
well you hold on to them don't you
and
and in terms of what so you're now
you've got the money you're ready to to
kind of begin the process of production
and was shooting in the after hebrides
always the plan or was it that you you
went there on a location scout and you
were just like this is the place um
and and and i'm assuming there haven't
been many things shot there have there
so there must have been an added
challenge with that as well
yeah so
i mean it so we're the first feature
film to have shot on on newest again it
was kind of taking things that i'd
learned from piccadero and applying them
to the process with limbo and that's
always kind of what i've said which is a
bit interesting is that like i always
see limbo as
my second
feature creatively
but it's my first feature
like in terms of the industry which
changes you know a huge amount
um
but creatively one of the things i did
with pikadero was that i built
location scouting into the writing
process
um
and so i wanted to do that again with
limbo so i got to the point where i
think it was actually the second draft
of screenplay and i was like you know
i've like i'm from edinburgh and i've
been
to sky and
um i've been to the highlands and things
i've not really been to a remote
scottish island like the one that i'm
writing about um so
i felt like i needed to go out there so
that's what i did and i i went out and
and ended up
you know going to this cottage in the
middle of nowhere with with no signal no
wi-fi
um
and writing the screenplay um
there um and so i'd write in the
mornings and i would travel or travel
around the island in the afternoons
and
discover and take photos of a lot of the
locations the majority of the locations
and actually the so planometric wide
shots that have that ended up in the
final film um
and
that was just hugely
useful to to to my process and
but then
what happened was that obviously euest
is very difficult to shoot on and it
could make the film
a lot more expensive
um so we
the the financiers kind of encouraged us
to to look elsewhere and see if there
was anywhere on the mainland or one of
the ideal islands are connected by a
bridge like sky
um
that would make it you know that would
lower the risk um so that's what we did
and we ended up traveling all around
scotland and we looked it's we looked at
cantire we looked at the northeast we
looked
we also looked around around sky a
little bit um
and what i did was basically take
uh location photos
in all of those different places and
then separate them out into documents
to present to the financiers
um and i really did try with the other
locations as well to kind of get the
best sort of like
shots to rep you know to show what what
the film would look like
um
and
presenting
those different places
it was just clear that eures was just
something else it was out of this world
um we hadn't seen these sort of this
sort of scotland on on in a kind of
fiction feature film before and it was
just very obvious to everyone like this
is where we we need to shoot this film
this is you know so
that kind of sold it um to the
financiers and then they kind of backed
us all the way to go and do that
in terms of the casting
um did you have people in mind for roles
as you were writing was it similar to
locations you were kind of envisioning
who you wanted to play your characters
or was it more of a search after you'd
written the screenplay
yeah i did start imagining people during
the writing process but i think i wasn't
you know it wasn't necessarily
it wasn't necessarily
thinking of of the final casting it was
just to kind of i think
it's sort of for something to kind of
creatively work within in the process to
me for me to kind of put a face to the
character like i actually
had um sally backery who is in
both of the films i mentioned um the
time that remains
and the band's visit um
so i'd always kind of had him in my in
my head
for uh for omar but he's a lot older now
so you know when i actually came to
casting you know
he he you know he wasn't suitable for
the for the role we we looked at
at casting
some
um non-actors in in these key roles as
well and you know i was quite keen to to
in a sort of like early stages i was
quite keen to to cast a syrian refugee
um
and
and also an afghan refugee and we looked
into that um
and we tried to do that but it was
very difficult um
for a number of different reasons but
also it's very difficult because it's
actually you know legally it's very
difficult to do that because the status
of a refugee and we came we had this
problem later on because we did have
real real refugees in the film and we
faced these problems because
they have to put down a profession
in their asylum application
and then they have to do that profession
so we were trying to basically we had to
employ them as actors but they're not
actually allowed to be actors because
they put another profession like being a
lawyer or whatever it is in their in in
their application we did a sort of
worldwide search um
for for the four main guys and
and then
no one was quite clicking for um omar
and i was kind of just spending my like
nights awake trying like googling
um actors
from the middle east that could play
this character and
and eventually came across a still uh
image um online of of of amir
and and it was just like i just when i
saw his face and it was actually a still
from the night manager
um
and i
yeah and just as soon as i saw him and i
was like that's omar he ended up doing
an initial
uh an initial
video audition taped audition and he was
brilliant from the very beginning and he
he kind of
really sort of got it um and then we
brought him in in person and it was just
a very very quick decision so he ended
up being the first person that that we
cast and and then with the others it was
different things going on we had like we
had improvised sessions
with uh vikash who who plays farhad
and
we brought him in to do like a half hour
hot seat improvised um so we interviewed
him in in character
um and that's kind of what ended up
getting him
the job after i think this was maybe
like
seven auditions or something like that
um
but he you know he was just by that it
was by that time he was you know he was
just so brilliant and he'd done so much
work because he's also
looked into the character um
he'd read everything sort of in in the
script but then that he could bring out
in this interview
uh
and also you know things about his
backstory and his relationship to omar
the first audition that he came to as
well he also had the mustache
and
so you know he he really sort of paid a
lot of attention to detail and he was
very committed
early on so i'm going to take us on to
the edit process now um and you have a
very specific style with your films um
and so do you have an editor that you
are constantly working with what is that
process of
of working with your editor do you do
you give them storyboards and go this is
what what the film is going to look like
or do you just give them the footage and
then go in and see that that first
assembly like what is what is that
process for you
it was a really interesting one with
limbo because we had we had a really
long post-production and it was
i mean that was
the main reason for that really was
because we just really wanted to make
the best film that we possibly could and
we really wanted to do justice to the
subject matter and we we
it was a huge amount of work that went
into
to balancing the tone of the film
and
to just
you know it's achieved really what you
know what i want wanted to achieve with
it and and
um
and we were afforded the space and time
to do that another
great thing that the financiers did was
that
they um just
allowed us to have the time
that we needed and
um one of the mistakes that we did i'm
kind of jumping ahead but i'll go back
one of the mistakes that that we made in
the process which is i think is
interesting for people to hear
is that
we we showed the finance series the film
too early so even though that they
were
you know
really sort of uh hands off and
allowed us to just kind of get done with
it
um
you know that these
people are part of the team and they're
really useful because they're really
useful to have
these kind of other you know eyes on on
the film and to feedback and you
and i realized because we didn't have
that with pikadero and i realized that
you know as the director
it's your job to
[Music]
it's not your job to tell everyone what
to do all the time it's your job to get
the most out of the people that you're
working with
and in my head i didn't i realized later
that it's also my job to get the most
out of the execs
um
and you don't think about that when with
your first feature you're like they're
like you kind of see them as kind of
like the bosses somehow yeah so that was
a mistake was showing them too early
when we weren't ready to show them when
we were still kind of finding the film
in in the edit
um
i think we showed them like a cut that
was like three hours long and i think
they were just like
and that was like a killer move you know
it was
creatively it was my second film i had
already worked with with carol and dolak
on piccadero
and he was out in u.s the entire entire
time
as well so he was
on the ground kind of
um
uh
he wasn't the d.i.t we had another dit
but he was sort of like organizing or
everything and kind of cutting bits um
together while we were there but i
didn't actually want to look at anything
while we were shooting we edited it in
san sebastian in spain which is where
we were
living at the time um that was also kind
of really
useful in a way it was really nice to be
sort of a way like to not be in london
at that point or to be in in edinburgh
or glasgow where
like basically people can turn up um
and so we were just sort of away in our
own space and where we could get get on
with things in terms of my process i go
in i'm there the entire time so i'm
i like to be very hands-on um
so it's basically it's very much like me
and carol working together um
the entire time and then
um at certain points
you know we'd talk about things and then
he would kind of go away and maybe cut
the scene or work more on a scene and
then come back and review it and then
work on that again that's what we did
for for quite a long time i'm not sure
how long it was but then we kind of
we got to a point where i felt like
um
[Music]
like i i felt like i
needed
another editor to come in
and get the film to the next point and i
was looking at something very specific
that was about
really about the rhythm of the film so a
lot of it was in place in terms of the
structure
um of it um
how the scenes were cut together how the
the sort of shape of of the story
but i i wanted to work more specifically
on on the rhythm of the film and i and i
always say rhythm because i don't i
don't know pacing is it doesn't quite
work for me like it was more about a
rhythm like a kind of musicality of how
we kind of move through the film
and
um
and so we brought on
lucia zucchetti and we moved the edit to
london and again this is it's important
to say that this like
this was entirely our own
decision that this was what we wanted to
do this wasn't something that we were
pressured into by execs or financials
just kind of stories that that you hear
this was something that creatively
we felt was the best thing
for the film and carol was very
understanding of that
um and lucia was very understanding of
the work that carol had done on the film
and also very unjust i'm kind of wanting
to retain
that you know what we had already sort
of achieved creatively and then i got to
the point where basically the film was
like 95
done
um and then i felt like
i wanted to bring carol back
to finish the film
because of the way that i work with with
carol specifically and that kind of
hands-on nature of it
um
and we needed to figure out actually
what we needed to figure out was the end
the the final um scene the concert
and so at that time carol was way up
north in there and we went up uh to now
in winter and it was snowing
and
we were finishing the film and this was
like i don't i'm not now i don't know
what the timeline was it's quite a long
long
process and
and then we just again work really
hands-on across a week or across two
weeks
um
finishing the film and just tying
everything together so in terms of of
the release of the film um it's you know
it's been so successful with festivals
and and then you've had you've had a
release period um in the cinemas as well
and you did some kind of set events
around around that as well i mean did
you did you have a plan of how you
wanted the release to go i mean
considering the subject matter as well
um was it always we're going to do
festivals first and then we're going to
do a cinema release was that always the
plan i mean for me the big kind of
ambition from the beginning of the
film the beginning very beginning of the
process
was to get the film to can
and that's been a big ambition of mine
you know since i started making films as
it kind of gained
momentum as we did get into cannes and
then we
and then the reception of the film in in
in toronto and in london and things like
that and we started to think about um
and as movie came on board
um
then
you know we we
we then it was a it was a lot of i i put
a lot of energy into that as well
because i really wanted
to get the most out of the theatrical
release and to kind of help
movie in any way that i could as as a
director and they were brilliant and
they were such a kind of pleasure to
work with they were they really
understood
the film and they really had a vision of
what to do
um with the film in terms of the
theatrical release you know the the big
thing obviously was the pandemic
which affected us throughout the
festival run because then you know we
got the can
label but the festival didn't go ahead
so you know we didn't have the premier
we didn't travel to toronto for the you
know with the only festival that we we
were able to attend in person with san
sebastian
and because we were there at the time
but it was very like very very reduced
when we were there and you know so it
was it was very strange going through
the festival
journey um
and you know and then with the award
season as well a similar thing with with
the the the baftas being online and then
we weren't able to attend after scotland
but it wasn't running as normal anyway
um and then with the theatrical release
when we released
i think that the cinemas were only at 25
capacity so um
but it felt like
it kind of gained momentum and it felt
like even with that 25 percent capacity
people
were seeing the film and responding to
so
yeah